all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with you guys I see a number of you
already in the live chat it's awesome
having you here I friend been a long
time mr. Roger Pierce another
entrepreneur advocate here in Toronto
and he is doing an article for sage and
just got off the live hangout with with
Stephen Kelly in London and he wanted to
ask me about how to use video to promote
your business so it's going to ask me a
couple questions but first off Roger
welcome aboard thank you have a nice to
be here do you want to tell the people
watching a little bit about what you're
all about he's in context absolutely for
sure I've got a small business
background I've had a lot of small
businesses 13 to be exact some have
succeeded some have failed and that let
me do a few companies Evan that you're
familiar with that we're all about
training and educating entrepreneurs and
that led to the business I'm in now
which is producing small business
content so I'm in a very lucky space we
get to work with large brands like sage
to produce helpful content articles
blogs infographics little tiny videos
nothing like your videos little tiny
advice videos ebooks those kinds of
things that help brands to help
entrepreneurs and start a conversation
all right and where can people find your
content on my website Pierce words com p
I erce words calm but also a big shout
out to our one of our favorite clients
sage calm / CA is where you can find out
more about which sage does for small
business I love it all right you have
some questions for me so Roger just
before we in the green when he's like
how did you look over the questions like
ah I don't really like looking over
questions I like just getting it wrong
first first reaction so hit me here we
go what you got for me give me something
good Roger let the questions begin i'll
start you with an easy one because you
are pretty familiar i'd say with this
medium why is video content so popular
these days i think people just like to
consume visually
I think for me I I would much rather
watch a video than read something then
listen to something I remember in my
early days of entrepreneurship I would
read up I had a book and I would read a
couple pages a day of entrepreneur
stories just to get me kind of motivated
and fired up and excited because there
wasn't anything else there was no video
option that I could turn to and I think
most people are just visual learners I
think it hits the senses faster and so
I'm just a fan I think a lot of people
are finding a video content supposed to
but there's anything around the written
word or you know podcast there's lots of
ways to market those things too but I
think people are just our visual
learners and if you are company or
entrepreneur try get your message out
there it's an amazing way to do it good
answer you know video is an important
part of the mix I'm sure you advocate
small business owners try to have a
Content mix some articles some videos
how important is it to do all of those
things some of those things how would
you suggest the average small business
owner balance out of content mix I think
you need to you need to understand what
your strengths are and I'm a big
believer in going all in on your
strengths if you are not great at
writing then don't write or or higher
Roger peers to come and write some
articles for you I think a lot of
entrepreneurs try to do too much and you
end up doing nothing well you do
everything in a really crappy way right
and now you got to be on snapchat too by
the way now you got to be on Twitter and
you're going to be on facebook and
either group and a page i need a youtube
channel oh and by the way you have to
write a business at the same time
there's no company whose it like an
entrepreneur doing all of that well
maybe the bigger brands whether have
teams of people doing it but as an
entrepreneur you get to figure out where
is your greatest skill and what are you
most interested in doing and then go all
in on that because your customers are
going to be everywhere for me I love
video um youtube is my biggest home and
I'm doing like if you can today I have
seven different live
dreams happening today to my audience we
got live audiences and all the masking
questions it's just so much easier for
me like so this is my default as an
example so for you guys watching Roger
reached out to me said hey we want to
feature an article for Sage I want to
know about your content marketing
strategy or is it awesome Roger how
about we do it as a YouTube hang out so
that I can promote you and also answer
any questions that you have and also
reason is I don't want to write I don't
want to write down the answers I'd much
rather make a video about it and it
helps me achieve my goal of adding dog
to my community well as well and helping
helping promote the people that are
interviewing me but almost all my
interviews now for written work is still
a video to start on my channel and it
just find it it's a much better way for
me to communicate if you suck in front
of a camera if you have no intention of
getting better you know getting in front
of a camera is just super terrifying for
you you don't have to do it like just
because I'm having success in other
people having success on YouTube or
snapchat it doesn't mean that you have
to go on and do it as well so it's
really finding the platforms that fit
your style best and I would advocate
going all in on those and so instead of
trying to do everything in a mediocre
way okay so a follow-up question to that
if an entrepreneur is really interested
in doing video Evan but is camera shy is
there another way for them to approach
doing video content um there's a number
of ways to do it I mean even me I was
camera shy at the start uh okay may not
come across now but this four thousand
videos almost on my channel so you
better lose camera shyness after four
thousand videos I would hope so I think
an easy way to get started is actually
with snapchat instead of YouTube because
it's just so easy you have your it's off
your phone it's meant to be not well
produced right like you can get judged
easily if you have a youtube video and
it's off your cell phone its wobbly or
whatever we're snapchat is an easy way
to get started
actually for the business I just
acquired the guy who I have running it
that's that's what he's doing he's doing
three snaps at least every day just to
get in the habit of being on camera and
at the start remember nobody's watching
you either right so you know you're
sucking but you're not sucking on stage
right there's nobody there watching you
and every time you do it you get better
you get a little more comfortable um and
you know you push yourself out of your
comfort zone I remember for me even when
I first start doing video I couldn't
have anybody in the room with me and I
had to wear that had to focus that would
have my sister or my wife or someone on
my team come in the room focus press
record leave the room and then I would
come and do my thing right I was too
nervous in front of other people to be
able to do it and then the next part was
the next like nervous thing I had the
breakthrough was doing it outside in
public so somebody challenged me hey why
don't you go do it on the streets it's
like doing on the streets like people
around that's crazy i'm not going to go
out with a camera and so the first one i
did I went outside and just make sure
there's nobody around and starting that
that released a fear a little bit and
then then I just kept doing it got more
and more used to it and now when I go
off on trips or whatever i'm always
vlogging they have the camera up and you
know people some people like who's this
crazy guys some people want to get in
and you don't be on camera so I think
like anything else practice helps you
get better you know when you first did
your first presentation I'm sure it
wasn't fantastic and then with practice
you got better like anything else that
we learn it's just more to the desire
like if you want to do YouTube just
because you think it's good for your
marketing you're probably not going to
have a lot of success at it if you want
to do video because you want to be able
to reach people in a visual way and
that's what you really want to be able
to learn to do then you'll fight through
all the crap and nerves and you know
terrible videos to get to we built the
skill to be good at it so like most
things in life you'll just get better
with practice you're saying
yeah yeah but but you have to want it
like if your mom is forcing you to play
piano yeah you'll get better at piano
but you'll never become you know god
tier at piano because you don't actually
want to do it it's just somebody forcing
you to do it and so you know you may
read an article saying here's why you
need to be on YouTube and it may make
sense to you like logically here but if
you're not feeling it here in your heart
if it's not really captivating and
emotional for you then you all you'll
give it a couple shots and then the guys
too hard and you'll quit and do
something else okay all right i'll buy
into that so let's say you've convinced
the small business owner all right i'm
gonna try video yeah how do you you know
what's the basic process of creating an
interesting topic recording it
publishing it promoting it there's a lot
of people up there that this scares the
heck out of them how to actually
technically do it what's the process can
you shed some light on what's worked for
you yeah I think I think the most
important video that everybody needs to
have is their foundation story
especially as an entrepreneur like why
are you doing this so even you let you
Roger you know I know you've been on
stage and you don't have the fright of
every you know a typical entrepreneur
might have but why is this this is so
important to you you know if you put
that up I maybe there is a video and I
haven't seen it but just as an example
you know I think every entrepreneur
needs to share that story because that's
that's your competitive advantage
because if you sell a similar product to
a big company why am I going to buy from
you there's this big company with all
this track record and history and
reputation and you know guarantees and
warranties and years of service why
would I ever buy from you the small
entrepreneur unless you're cheaper and I
don't want the entree to be cheaper I
want them the more expensive and so why
would I ever buy from you when you have
no branding and no name recognition
because of the story because I feel your
passion because I feel like I'm going to
get a better result by going with this
individual who really cares deeply about
their business then company XYZ where
I'm just another number and so a lot of
entren is make a mistake in that they
have a really boring corporate website
where that doesn't
tell their story that doesn't make me
feel that personal connection and so
that's your biggest competitive Vantage
I feel as an entrepreneur and so if you
could I think everyone trainees to tell
their story in some way at least at
least a smiling picture and copy to tell
their story but if you can go in the
next level do a video but people aren't
expecting you to be the greatest like if
I'm hired a plumber I don't need plumber
man to be the greatest video on screen
personality but I want to hear his
passion for plumbing right like I want
him to tell me about how he grew up with
his father who was a plumber and learned
the ropes and every time he goes to a
house he treats it like his father's
house like that's the plumber that I
want to have and you can tell that story
in a in a heartfelt way without having
to be amazing on camera so i think that
that is the first video that every
entrepreneur should ideally make and
you'll come back to it like in six
months if you keep doing more video you
realize how bad that first one was and
you want to make it better and so like
you may end up doing multiple revisions
of your about video how we lost Roger
Roger left I don't know what happen the
Roger all right hopefully come [ __ ] in
um the second thing that I would say
just going on that tangent is i would
start looking at questions from your
your customers this is something that
I'm doing with Toronto that's also right
now we've got a lot of people who are
one in the center for classes and alex
is making videos Alex helps me on the
company answering the common questions
like what do you expect to happen on the
first day of class or what clothes
should i wear do I need special clothes
or special shoes or anything special i
need to bring to the first class right
so common questions that people would
ask you can turn those into videos and
you should be an expert right like as an
entrepreneur you're an expert you should
be an expert you should know your
content inside out people are coming to
you for a reason if you don't have
expertise then it's hard to really make
a business right you're doing
something different special unique and
so showing off that expertise whether
it's an article or video and we're
talking about video here and Roger ass
how how do you get started that's what I
would look at I would look at how do I
share my expertise by look at the common
questions and it's also value add for
people who are uncertain about you know
buying your thing and they don't want to
write in they can see that video on your
website or if somebody writes in with an
email you can answer it and then also
send them the video because if people
see you again to the cut to the comment
I made earlier before about making
visual content like people are visual
learners if they see you and they you
know they like you right like if they
feel the passion they feel the care
they're much more likely to connect with
you like look at this as an example
right me talking here right now you guys
watching live you feel more connected to
me you take in the message more than if
it was just text right or if it was just
a do-right are you guys that's connected
right now that we're just doing audio no
right you want to see the video and so
you could do that same thing for your
business people will connect with you a
lot better if if you can get those
videos out so that's what I would start
with start with your foundation story
why this business is so important to you
what it means to you and then common
questions that people ask in your
business and then you can refer people
onto I think from there you should be
able to think about them the most common
20 questions that you get asked in your
business and it may even happen speed up
the sales process for you because now
instead of answering every question with
a long email you can link them up to the
video so you get a better result and you
save time as well I think from there
your community will start to take over
so pay attention to the comments look at
somebody who's leaving a comment on the
video thank you so much but what about
this what about that and all of the
videos that I have
my channel started off as questions from
my audience and then comments some
people who asked the question right and
now they're all requests around almost
videos a request our top 10 or an
espresso believe life all of that
they're almost all requests I think that
helps you with any business I think if
you have a any kind of interesting video
I think the foundation story ID leaves
with every single business even if it
makes you feel uncomfortable even you
don't feel you know if you feel awkward
on camera because again I'm not
expecting you to be you know Beyonce or
Matt Damon or anybody on camera I just
wanted I want you to be you I want to
hear your story I think that benefits
everybody every entrepreneur I think the
decision to then make other videos
around common questions could still help
most entrepreneurs but it's a dedication
to making the films whether you're doing
it off your DSLR camera or you're going
to go and get a camera or get something
to help you has a camera I wouldn't go
out and buy a lot of the gear maybe I'll
just that quickly after but answering
the questions and most common questions
of people that people are given you
whether you then want to make the jump
to be coming you know YouTube as a
business is a totally different story
for me that's when it that's when I
started making videos that I wanted to
see so wasn't just answering questions
from people I needed these videos in my
life I wanted the top 10 I want the
interest so that's why I created it and
I shared it with you guys and thankfully
you guys like to see it as well I don't
think that's a path for most
entrepreneurs most entrepreneur going to
go off and become full-time youtubers
right that's again but if you think
about the kinds of videos that you would
want to see to be able to make an impact
so as an example with Toronto dance
salsa we're looking at making a short
film like two minutes short film super
short film just telling a story about
somebody who feels like they're an
outsider and then they come to the
school are they come dancing
to the school just go dancing and they
find a way out they find a way to be
connected they find a way to be holding
they took that leap you know to do
something new and they got acceptance so
those kinds of stories could be helpful
for four people as well but it's
definitely not for everybody so Delmon
for everybody your foundation story
almost everybody 10 to 20 frequently
asked questions and videos just you
being authentic and honest and then if
you want it if you're liking it you're
getting value from at us any more time
then you can think about content that
you really want to create in terms of
setting up a lot of people feel like
it's expensive they need all the gear
and I think that's the worst place to
start the worst thing you can do is go
out and buy gear and by you know by the
camera by the lights and by the stand by
the background and buy all that stuff to
make a great video because you may just
do two videos in the side you know what
this sucks I don't want to do this this
isn't for me and you're stuck with all
those gears sit in your garage that you
can't take back or get rid of just like
when you're starting a business don't go
out and order 10,000 units before you've
gone out and sold a couple right small
batches to see if it works and then
expand from there so in terms of
execution start with your phone start
with the camera start you have a DSLR
camera likely talk to a friend the first
videos that I put up were one either
with my own camera which was a little
flip camera they don't I don't think
they're rallying more flip was their own
flip camera that I just I just put on a
shelf I like standing in front of a
bookcase and I put it on the bookcase
press record and some of them were
wobbly because the camera was still
wobbly so you see my face kind of going
like this it's putting Barry seen um hey
Roger sorry about that good grief it's
all good i was i was going on i'm just
getting too i know if you want to talk
about is getting too like how to get
started with the year I don't care I
don't know if tears on your list of
questions or not oh well sorry about
that complete total
malfunction just shut down on me dog
gave in okay well this is life in the
video business my question for you was
all about having something to say Evan
how does an entrepreneur who says you
know what I've got nothing to say on
video can you give me some suggestions
on topics how do I come up with
something that's interesting for an
audience right so so I kind of went on a
rant about this while you are gone so
it's good haha the vs. your foundation
story and in there there should be
something to say like why did why did
you start this you you know you weren't
happy with something you wanted to fill
a need you wanted to help somebody out
you know you better be certain the
business for more than just oh I wanted
to make money you know but there's got
to be a strong reason there for starting
a company and then I suggested doing the
common questions that you get asked from
your clients already so I use the
example of trying to dance salsa you
know what do I expect on the first day
of class what shoes do I need to wear
you know there anything I need to be
concerned about and then making videos
about whatever business you have your
ass the same kinds of questions
constantly from your audience from your
customers or potential customers and so
you can make videos on each of those and
it's a great way to be able to connect
with people i went on a big rant about
it so you should watch the replays
probably helpful thanks for filling in
the gap well I disappeared obviously
you're you're big on social media you've
got thousands and millions of followers
what I don't expect to give you a social
media a lesson here but for a small
business owner again they produce some
video how do they get it out there can
you give them some suggestions some
simple steps to start to embrace social
media sure it's understanding I wouldn't
just create a video and then try to get
it out there I think you need to create
content for the platform also its
understanding weary but where you want
to live so if you're making a YouTube
video it's different than out doing than
making a facebook video or from a
snapchat video for an Instagram video
what people expect the you know the
snapchat video is going to be square are
sorry Instagram videos going to be
square and only last a minute right a
snapchat video gives you 10
seconds and you want to use the filters
and so it's really hard to get good
promotion cross-platform most of my
youtube stuff my promotion and execution
and awareness comes with it from within
YouTube drive promoted on my Twitter yes
or put on my facebook yes put in my
newsletter yes website yes it all helps
a little bit but really like ninety-five
percent of it just comes from within the
YouTube ecosystem so I'd be making a
video with purpose for the platform so
if you know if I want to really be on
Facebook that's where I want to dominate
then make a video for facebook and then
you can promote it the other spots but
don't really expect a huge lift except
from the platform you're promoting it
okay that's a great tip and I'm just
watching our time here I know I've only
got a couple minutes so I'm going to
start to wrap it up and just sort of say
you know can you suggest three takeaways
for a small business owner who's just
getting into this idea video content
what are three things you want them to
remember points or tips you want to
remember in terms of producing and
distributing their own video content one
expect a sock at the start serious
you're going to look at you you're going
to record a video it's going to take you
the whole day to do it because you're
going to do 30 takes you're going to
hate every single take and then you're
going to feel like this isn't for you so
expect this up just like anything else
when you first got on skis you fell down
every time all the way down the hill
right you you will get better so just
expect it because nobody talk you you
probably look at somebody's youtube
channel say oh wow I could I want to do
something like that and then you go and
try it and you know what looks good and
then you see what you made and see this
huge gap and you feel terrible and you
just gonna quit so don't quit expect the
suck just do it better than you did the
last time I think to say something
meaningful I would try to tap into a an
emotional state and I get that it's hard
when you're on camera and that's why
that's why I may take a couple extra
takes two but telling your story or
answering a question don't just answer
the question tie it into something more
personal tied into
more meaningful more emotional more
powerful for you because that's the
whole point is I want to be able to make
a connection with you so don't just give
me a sales pitch it's super boring give
me a story that ties into me get an
answer to that question and then three
would just be practice like I got good
because I kept doing it like the
quantity leads to the quality so just
keep practicing keep practicing keep
practicing every time you do it you'll
get a little bit better and just
compared yourself to the last take of
yesterday's video and with time you'll
continue to improve part of that getting
better evan is that include listening to
feedback from viewers on your on your
material uh yeah but at the start you
have no viewers right like for most
people there's not a big audience so but
your viewers could be your friends other
entrepreneurs you might send an email to
customers um so yes it's listen to
feedback I think I think at the start
you're your own worst critic anyway you
look at it and say oh man like I blink
so many times or you know I was picking
my ear there at that point whatever I
like so you're gonna want to you don't
even want to send anybody yet because
there's so many things you want to fix
yourself and if anything the audience
boost you up said you know what that
wasn't that bad like I really liked that
point me really I thought I sucked right
so uh I said it took me like seven
hundred videos 800 videos before I
wasn't embarrassed by my own stuff
embarrassed like I still put it up but
but I look at it Oh what is that so bad
so so I think any feedback is good I
think though I think you might be
surprised and that the people you send
it to will just be more supportive than
anything and you'll be your own worst
critic at the start as you build up like
if you you know at your stage now Roger
you've done a lot of presentations you
you know you've done interviews now you
may need some you know if you wanted to
do this full time to get on YouTube you
may want to go to a coach or have
somebody else look at or somebody else's
you on YouTube right like I'm happy to
look at or whatever for feedback on how
to get better because you've kind of
outgrown the audience like they're all
saying it's great but you know you want
to get better like you're not Anthony
Robbins level yet so now I need coaching
advice on how to get there those are
fantastic tips this has been really
insightful and it's gonna make a great
article for sage I appreciate your time
Evan I love it so they're going to wear
sage that's sage calm / CA yeah that's
what's going to live and when is it
going to come out ah that's a very good
question i will keep you posted probably
the next couple months it has to go
through the usual approval processes but
because it's from you i'm sure that'll
be short and sweet whatever I trust you
made for my approval process it's up
well thank you very much that's great
well people are right into the chat
greeting of you Roger Navin is uh
there's 34 people watching live right
now so thank you guys for watching hope
you have an amazing day go check out
Rogers site as well I believe it's
linked up in description continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you soon great job Roger
thanks Evan